ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hippodrome de longchamp s'est mise en
robe d'été pour la plus grande course de
l'année le grand prix de paris
ces chevaux au départ 40 millions au
bout de la ligne droite des tribunes
après 3000 m de galop sous un soleil de
plomb du plomb les concurrents non sous
leurs sabots le train n'est pas très
rapide
c'est peut-être pour faire durer le
plaisir les turfistes ont ainsi quelques
secondes supplémentaires de rêve
[Musique]
de fait on reste très groupée dans le
peloton c'est toujours le délai de grâce
[Musique]
jusqu'à la ligne droite où les coeurs
commence à battre un peu plus vite les
40 millions c'est pour bientôt et bien
avant la ligne d'arrivée c'est déjà pour
balto commente maxime garcia
l'heureuse élue comme dans un fauteuil
avec quatre longueurs d'avancé
[Musique]
ermenonville en cinq petites escale chez
jean richard qui fête en compagnie de
quelques amis le cinquième anniversaire
de son réseau outre les animaux sauvages
en richard n'a pas oublié les monstres
sacrés qui eux n'ont pas besoin de cas
[Musique]
sa part et méchant mais c'est tout
tendre ces petites bêtes là alors là
georges guétary soyez prudents ce gentil
petit pensionnaire pèse 400 kg fait le
beau pour voir un peu et oui c'est l'un
des plus grandioses du monde de mettre
60 des pieds à la tête
avec lui pas de danger il est très
sociable et plein de malice avec cela
pas encore majeur mais déjà fumeurs
comme un an
[Musique]
aux yeux du monde la visite qu'a fait à
paris le président de la république
ouest allemande monsieur lübke haute
avec son épouse du général de gaulle or
a souligné un événement d'importance
l'une des plus audacieuses
réconciliation de l'histoire
cet arc de triomphe où monsieur luc que
s'est recueilli sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu qu on a pu mesurer tout le
chemin parcouru par deux pays déchiré en
moins d'un siècle par trois guerres
monsieur léopold senghor président de la
république du sénégal avait revêtu ce
jour-là sa toge et son hermine de
professeurs de lettres pour présider à
la distribution des prix dans un lycée
de dacca dans une époque trop souvent
troublées par des antagonismes ratio on
peut constater que parmi tous ces
adolescents
personne ne songeait à la différence de
couleur de peau personne ne songeait à
la considérer comme autre chose que ce
qu'elle ait une différence de
pigmentation
c'est un des exemples les plus
réjouissant que donne aujourd'hui les
pays africains de langue française
[Musique]
abbas les directeurs de cinéma ont
obtenu leur 16e congrès au cours duquel
ils se sont élevés contre la fiscalité
et les films audacieux où il voit les
deux monde du septième art
entre deux réunions ils ont aussi
sacrifié à la tradition champenoise en
visitant les caves ce qui en aucun cas
ne saurait être considérée comme une
audace
à saint symphorien en eure et loir
monsieur robert buron ministre des
travaux publics a inauguré en compagnie
notamment de son excellence le général
kevin ambassadeur des états unis
le buste élevé à la mémoire du général
patton tatane le nom d'un char sans
doute mais aussi celui du héros de la
percée d'avranches un nom qu'en france
on ne peut oublier le nouveau musée du
havre a été inaugurée par monsieur andré
malraux avec son signal de 200 tonnes il
sera le premier bâtiment qu'on
découvrira du large toutes ensemble
musée et maison de la culture
c'est là une création unique dans son
genre un musée révolutionnaire qu'on dit
en avance de 50 ans avec des panneaux
escamotable et des balcons sur deux
faces tout en acier et en verre et qui
est le 900 38e musées français
[Musique]
tandis que l'agitation paysanne gagnait
d'autres régions les agriculteurs
bretons ont perdu à morlaix leur
principale raison de manifester le
tribunal a acquitté messieurs gourvennec
et leon
relax et des fins de poursuites comme
dit la sentence les deux dirigeants se
sont retrouvés libre au milieu de dix
mille paysans bretons est ce la mince de
la détente chez ces derniers mais nous
avons vu la semaine dernière que le mal
dont souffre la bretagne n'est pas que
d'ordre agricole cette province de
france qui est la plus particulariser
dont l'ancien parlement de rennes et les
jetons de présence à l'éffigie de louis
saez rappelle son attachement à ses
libertés et qui a gardé le privilège de
conserver sa langue est trop longtemps
passé à côté du progrès mais la
situation n'est pas sans espoir
un service régulier d'avion fonctionne
depuis cette année c'est déjà un progrès
et c'est une promesse d'avenir que
l'importante usines d'automobiles que
citoyenne achève aux portes de rennes
le premier gros consommateurs de main
d'oeuvre qui permettra qui permet déjà
d'amorcer la diminution d'une émigration
qui atteint le chiffre impressionnant de
vingt mille exilés volontaires par an
on s d'avenir encore le chantier de la
rance qui dotera la bretagne de la
première centrale marémotrice du monde
et les sondages de brennilis qui sont à
l'origine de la centrale nucléaire
expérimental au pied des monts d'arrée
promesses plus immédiate et plus
efficaces aussi la centrale à turbines à
gaz de bresse pordic qui fonctionnera
suivant le principe des moteurs à
réaction et qui aura une puissance de 20
mille kilos à guingamp où se concentrent
chaque jour des cageots empli de poulet
c'est déjà une réalité
guingamp est aujourd'hui une espèce de
chicago du poulet électrocuté seigner et
chaud des plumes et 200000 infortunés
poulet passent chaque semaine dans la
chaîne infernale emporté au rythme
ininterrompu de l'automation étrange et
inquiétant dallest qui nous emporte bien
loin de l'image de la bretagne
traditionnels
l'enchanteur merlin et la fée viviane
ont depuis longtemps déserté la forêt de
brocéliande et leur baguette magique et
casser les tours du château d'anne de
bretagne n'abrite plus que des souvenirs
et du déclin comme les jacques cartier
les surcouf les duguay trouin reste
comme le symbole du caractère breton
on a pu comparer à ce granit dont on
hardatit saint malo seul aujourd'hui
l'énergie qui anime les usines réalisera
le miracle qu'attend la bretagne d'année
à cette terre de tradition de caractère
sa place dans le monde moderne
[Musique]
au liban byblos offre à celui qui
emprunte le chemin des barques
phénicienne bien autre chose que le
pittoresque d'un quelconque hors de la
côte méditerranéenne
une confrontation avec 7000 ans
d'histoire
les fouilles menées depuis 40 ans par
des archéologues français sur l'antique
acropole ont fait surgir les vestiges
superposés d'une vingtaine de
civilisation et on y découvre
aujourd'hui des poteries vieille de sept
mille ans ainsi devant les restes des
maisons phénicienne peut-on rêver aux
hommes d'il ya 50 siècles qui enterrait
encore leur mort dans les jardins mais
stick
quelques pins et on peut évoquer la
grandeur de rome qui édifia là aussi son
théâtre antique et ses temples
[Musique]
quelques pas encore au delà d'une
sculpture brisé et voici révélé le temps
des croisades avec les fortifications
franck qui sacrifièrent les colonnes
romaines à leurs remparts et qui
marquèrent la fin de quatre cent
soixante sept ans de domination arabe
dont au fond du puits du roi le tombeau
date sheeran conserve la trace
byblos un prodigieux raccourcie de sept
mille ans de l'histoire des hommes
[Musique]